Everybody experiences
hiccups from time to time.
I think most people would agree
that one hiccup is sort of funny,
two hiccups in a row is really funny
and three hiccups in a row
is where it starts to be concerning,
in part because hiccups
can be kind of painful.
There is a technique that can
reliably eliminate hiccups
and it's a technique that takes advantage
of hypercontracting the phrenic nerve
over a short period of time
so that it then subsequently relaxes
or alleviates the spasming
of the phrenic nerve.
And that simple method is to
inhale three times in a row.
This is a very unusual
pattern of breathing
but what it involves is
taking a big deep inhale
through your nose,
then before you exhale any air,
take a second inhale through the nose,
however brief that inhale might be,
and then a third even
micro or millisecond long
inhale through your nose
to get that third inhale
and then hold your breath
for about 15 to 20 seconds
and then slowly exhale.